Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
What's up?
Nothing much.
And you?
Same here.
Same as usual.
Oh, hey, do you like soccer?
Well, I don't play soccer but I like watching the games.
How about you?
I love it.
I played soccer this morning, too.
Aren't you tired?
How often do you play soccer?
Twice a week.
Wednesday and Sunday morning.
I might have to do that, too.
I'm getting fat.
Well, try yoga then.
It's the best way to lose weight.
I know but I prefer outdoor activities.
How about cycling?
I used to do cycling and I'll tell you this.
It can be boring.
How about this, I'm going to the gym tonight.
We can work out together.
That sounds fun!
I always wanted to get a six-pack.
Pardon?
What is a "six-pack"?
Muscles in your abs.
Oh, my brother has a six-pack.
It's not hard.
It just takes time.
Are you serious?
Yes, give it a try.